a Greg what's her first headline our
first headline on this election night
was from the world the football that
Donald Trump in his administration
produced a political ad that was deemed
racist by basically everyone that saw it
that depicted the caravan of migrants if
you're listening to this I'm sure you
know about it right now and it was less
that the commercial was controversial
but more the surprise that NBC and other
networks including Fox chose to air it
before later saying they will no longer
air it and now what was racist I've not
seen the ad what was racist about the ad
basically that it was using Mexican
immigrants but not even their caravans
on on the side of Mexico that using them
to basically stoke fear that they're
going to come to our country and then
you know comparing the caravan to this
terrible criminal who is talking and
about how proud he was to have killed
all these people and basically trying to
make people think think the Mexicans are
coming and they're gonna kill you all
that makes the caravan scent awesome
that makes the caravan sound like it's
like a party coming to your town you
know what I mean like it's like the
spuds Mackenzie of caravans that you're
just like oh these guys are gonna kick
ass like here's my question Greg do you
think do you think if the Caravan teamed
up with the Alabama Crimson Tide
football team could they beat the
Oakland Raiders know I'm always insulted
by these questions why like you always
hear it a lot on like sports talk radio
it's like you know could could Alabama
right now you know compete with the
Buffalo Bills on that offense could they
stop them
that's ridiculous but you're forgetting
about the caravan right add the caravan
in that's a deep team they're tough but
I think people under eight the
difference in toughness that you're
going up a level not just from college
football I mean only the best of the
best from Alabama are getting into the
NFL but also the toughness that would
have to go up for that Caravan playing
in front of 80,000 people in the black
hole think about how many of those
people in that Caravan have already died
caravanning up here do you know what I
mean they're not in
they're not they don't have like RVs you
know I mean they're walking and they're
getting their cardio in and I think what
could nick saban a genius like Nick
Saban do with that Caravan you know what
I mean how could he figure them in into
like into just kickoffs do you know I
mean like could he judge what skill set
from the caravan do you think is gonna
be particularly applicable to to playing
football let's say the caravans 100
people okay let's see one of them
actually killed somebody I think that's
pretty valuable in a football field you
know I mean I think he could I think you
can take out he could take out Oakland
quarterback I think it's respectful to
Jon Gruden and the Raiders and all these
players who had to survive getting
through the draft process making the
team getting on the 45min roster
practicing in the offseason playing on
Sundays it's like the caravan hasn't put
in the work they haven't put in the time
these guys have been doing it since
they're eight years old that's truces
the first time anyone's been
disrespectful to Jon Gruden this year
what do you think about this let's say
the caravan comes across and Alabama
lines about one side of the field rather
than the other and they get to pick you
know what I mean they divide the caravan
up equally what's the final score that
game I mean 64 to 17 Raiders okay let's
say let's say straight up caravan versus
the Raiders just a caravan coached by
Saban caravan coached by Saban versus
the Oakland Raiders coached by Gruden
what's the finals 192 2 3 caravan
Raiders you think the Raiders would wind
up I did I think the caravan wants it
more
I think the caravan I think the Kerr
fans fired up and and think about this
they've taken the first eight weeks of
the season off dude I mean they they're
not you don't fresh legs but they're
mentally focused yeah I think the the
journey they've been on is gonna take a
lot mentally I welcome the caravan and I
think that all of our professional
athletes should challenge them at some
point
to see who's the best professional
sports teams or a migrant caravan that
has somehow been villainized for no
reason other than they can't beat a
professional football team okay they
don't even practice they probably never
seen a football
soccer you United States soccer team
versus the caravan that's a closer
that's a closer match up I didn't the
caravan caravans much bigger and I think
they're probably more used to playing
soccer than the United States soccer
team I'm gonna give it to the caravan
and that was how cools the caravan III
know you're excited about this one post
Malone one of your favorite artists made
the news this week because he made a
pair of Crocs and he personalized them
put some silly stuff on it and they sold
out in about ten minutes yeah we were
all excited about the story Crocs are
fascinating to me I've never worn a pair
my feet in them but I like that the
company got in trouble basically because
their Crocs are so indestructible that
you only had ever buy one pair and that
was it and they were like oh now we're
screwed so I enjoy watching them
struggle to keep their they're doing
well right now I think I think Crocs are
kind of back I think they've figured out
some strategy but number years ago
talking about this reading an article
about it well if you wear tie my kids
with my kids are extracts that's because
I might even get into it why your kids
wear Crocs I wish you did not get into
the feet binding thing but you guys
decided to be traditional and bound them
with Crocs and and I'd you know i think
it's child cruelty to be honest but if
we all had our own line of crocs Greg
what would your Crocs be mine would they
would have little symbols they would
have a little bags of turkey jerky they
would have some tennis balls they would
have a junior VP logo and then like the
front of it would be my nose just like
leading with the honker like a finger as
part of the shoe or just no no it'd be
kind of drawn that would be drawn into
the shoe so it'd just be a bunch of
different little images tennis balls
turkey jerky junior VP and my big nose
okay in the way doesn't like the Uglies
crux of all time listen my Crocs black
like a shiny black like oh my god is
like is the night time coming from me
black little red lightning bolts on the
side punk rock little lightning bolts on
the side and ten minutes after you put
them on for the first time they explode
sending pieces of your feet everywhere
those would be the Justin that Crocs I
bet they sell nine minutes post him
alone
I'm gonna send toes to like the four
corners of the continent are you worried
about the reviews they'll come out and
people will be a little little scared do
I sound like a worry about reviews no I
only care about one thing that's the
care of that
[Music]
you